good morning John and good morning
nerdfighters to see you know we're a
tribe and not only are we a tribe we're
a very advanced tribe Jonathan on
average we're probably about a level
four tribe and there is a really good
chance that you have no idea what I'm
talking about so I'm going to ask you to
go spend ten minutes watching Dan
Brown's new video while I sit very still
there's a link somewhere on here you
should click on it oh my god I'm so bad
at sitting still
so to summarize the video that you
obviously just watch don't tell me that
you didn't go see it here is the basic
idea we are all members of tribes but
individuals inside of the tribe can
operate on a lot of different levels
they can operate on the assumption that
life sucks they can operate on the
assumption that their life sucks or they
got right on the assumption that they're
great and you're not now those are the
firts three levels of tribes now I think
John that nerdfighteria is a level four
tribe and that means more than we're
just awesome it means that we operate on
the assumption that we are great and
because we recognize that we can do
really awesome things like happy dance
projects and yearly gatherings on
YouTube to promote charities another
really interesting thing that I just
realized is that what you want to do
cool stuff it does not matter what you
can do it matters what you think you can
do during the peak of Renaissance
culture in Florence Italy which was like
the peak of the Renaissance at the peak
of the Renaissance there were about
60,000 people there that is fewer people
then are subscribed to the vlogbrothers
YouTube videos and among those 60,000
people you have Michelangelo da Vinci
Machiavelli Raphael dozens more of these
absolute geniuses doing absolutely
beautiful and amazing things so I think
that what I'm about to say is quite
obvious if there are 60,000 people
watching this then there is a
Michelangelo a DaVinci a Machiavelli in
a Raphael all watching this right now
what you can do is about what you think
you can do and it's about the community
in which you're doing it so in Dan
Brown's video he asks us to do a few
things first he wants us to suggest
projects that we as a community can pull
off together then he wants us to do a
dance and then he wants us to leave that
that he was a video response to his
video I am now going to do all those
things so here's my idea for
really awesome project that I am really
excited about that
I want nerdfighters to participate in I
have a friend who is going to the
Democratic Republic of Congo and she is
going there for real
to teach digital journalism to Congolese
students she's gonna give them cameras
and video editing software and she's
going to teach them how to make awesome
videos about their lives in the Congo
this to me represents an opportunity to
really shrink the boundaries of the
world you know and I watch people's
YouTube videos I find myself caring
about them but interestingly there
aren't a lot of Congolese people making
youtube videos so it could be sometimes
a little bit harder to understand those
people complexly and to really care
about their lives and is going there to
make that not be an issue anymore
unfortunately as you might imagine there
aren't a lot of cameras or camcorders in
the Congo so I find out about this
problem I was like the nerdfighters can
help with that problem so I'm asking all
of you to reach into your desk drawers
and deep into your heart they need
cameras that are above 6 megapixels and
anything that can capture video and
export it either through firewire or USB
they actually have computers they just
don't have the cameras she's also hoping
to get any digital audio recorders and
any headphones any headphones at all
that are like better than earbuds in
return ands gotta go to the Congo and as
soon as her students start producing
videos we'll be featuring them on
nerdfighters comm and possibly right
here on the bar brothers there of course
is an address to send all those things
to in the doobly-doo and now you know
one more way that YouTube and the
nerdfighters are gonna be making awesome
things happen thank you all so much in
advance for donating your equipment and
now it's time for me to do my dance the
mix lost history
John you'll see me tomorrow